[Music]
the problem is that nobody tells you is
that at 72 years old you spend the next
20 years of your life in regret because
you weren't happy and that is not
[ __ ] easy
you got your perspective everybody you
listen to a little bit of sports card
conversation with Mark Lori and I
actually mark why don't you first
introduce yourself and I will get into
it a little bit about who you are and
and then we'll get right into it
sure yeah no I'm currently running
Walmart's e-commerce business but uh you
know I've always been an entrepreneur
started a bunch of businesses sold on
Amazon sold the recent went to Walmart
that's how I got part of Walmart and
been running Walmart's econ business the
last three and a half years now so Sega
way back where'd you grow up I grew up
in Staten Island New York until I was
about how old are you now fifth grade I
I'm 48
cake you go to about fifth grade fifth
grade and then move to a place called
Lincroft New Jersey right next to Red
Bank New Jersey exhibit 109 on the
Parkway because that's what people do
when they talk about Jersey true
right near Bruce Springsteen actually I
was I still I actually went to the same
gym as Bruce when I was 16 years old I
was in the gym and he was we're both
just two people in the gym downstairs
you know in the kind of garage and he
like looks over he goes hey man you want
to spot me on the bench press that was
like oh my god I went to school the next
day I'm like you know who asked me to
spot them nope no photos back then yeah
exactly what kind of kid were you I was
very scrappy entrepreneurial liked it
every business you could possibly manage
it as a kid from lemonade stand it's a
really little kid to car washes lawn
mowing weed picking newspapers shoveling
it snow shoveling that was a big one for
me in this yeah I mean Jersey I mean
anything and I was I would basically
just outwork anyone it's funny one of my
friends go ahead that's it yeah my
friend reached out to me is like you
grew up with me is like you know you've
told all the
good stories about us his kids he's like
but you haven't talked about your
biggest huh
hustle business and I'm like and I was
excited I was like what he's like bro
you don't remember that in Christmastime
we would gather together and you would
ring the door we would ring people's
doorbell and say hey ma'am would you
like to pay us a dollar for singing
Christmas carols he's like you were a
nice Jewish boy ringing the doorbell and
saying hello ma'am
would you like to pay us a dollar for
Christmas cows hit it boys
dashing through the snow literally
anything for a buck yeah I was like uh
so great so obviously I so super hard to
you know like it would be like I would
just like pick weeds for like 12
straight hours and it was like fine you
know back if you moved in fifth grade so
you were older than me great so like
literally when you were in Jersey and I
was I was you know 25 exits away from
you which means we basically got the
same snowstorms yeah and and when I tell
you that my friends still resent me for
the fact because I was also a
charismatic leader as a kid so I could
get the energy up everyone would run
outside no school Nirvana everybody run
outside sleds in hand ready to go and I
would literally will everybody after a
20-minute conversation into literally
shoveling snow for nine hours but it
caught me a lot I had the same I had the
same kind of mentality it was just weird
it was it was in you yeah people always
ask me they're like how'd you learn I'm
like it was in here I didn't read them
they're a business book and when I was
sick by the way we were talking about
sports cards so what I also did in high
school is I started a company called the
mint which basically bought cards direct
from the manufacturers and I all summer
long put together sets with my really
close friend lacs we would everybody
needs elack's
yeah relax relax Chandra lacks was first
name yeah oh I thought I thought Lacs
was like classic like Mike cut it short
Lacs was the first thing short for
Lakshman yeah I love it and and we would
literally go in the basement what your
size is eighty seven seven yeah the
worst possible years yep
the reason I guessed it before you said
it we put these hundreds of sets bro it
was the apex moment yeah every single
kid for Hanukkah and Christmas during
the 87 set got in every kid in my junior
high got a set of 87 times that was an
86 tops traded the year before yeah but
that was harder to get stuff you have to
go to the u.s. one flea market yeah do
you remember that we used to order dude
we had it we ordered array you were a
little more advanced to me we had the 86
top tray we go to sports you know
trading show you that American parents
that probably knew how to do that Miley
also bought like a thousand pete
incaviligia of course a monster monster
that was I I actually didn't go after
Pete but I went after Benito Santiago
I went heavy on Benito Santiago I all
with Eric Davis oh I thought Eric Davis
was not Eric Davis - so Eric Davis and
pete incaviligia listed - but Eric Davis
we learned my we learned a really good
lesson we had like 200 Eric Davis's
stolen it was out on the trade show and
a thing and we just turn around like
where's Eric Davis where's Eric Davis
somebody stole yeah what I have 200 yeah
I table you know it's cool it's crazy
the other guy you know who I got
murdered on Cory Schneider
oh yeah the Olympic card got destroyed
on him I thought he was there I thought
he was Pete Rose and the making that was
that era but you know it's funny where
did you do shows malls JCC's yeah fire
stations all that show right [ __ ] yeah
we had the same up I mean makes so much
sense that we have so much crossover it
makes so much sense
okay started I started to this the thing
a right idea but didn't know about about
really grading at the time but well
greeting I'm basically you know but
every Cal Ripken jr. I could find and
this was you know before he really
became like you know what he is today
get hot because he had a hitting streak
cuz I remember I went to a bar mitzvah
around that time and everyone's talking
about Ripken like he was just such a
great player at that point - yeah but
you had Wookiees 82 tops yeah 82 tops I
just had like three majors up and then
it turns out like I went to recently you
know what to get him valued of course
they're not graded and people looking at
him and going I thought this was meant
but now it's like a six it's like
because when you and I were in the game
int here's why cuz you and I came up in
the game when there was nothing around
centering yeah it was all corners
increases no it was all corners who else
thought was min still the difference
like min starts it like you know six or
seven now and then you get the really
eight and then nine and antennas like
gentlemen perfect you know when did
cards become not cool to you like what
happened so you're a little bit older
than me so it kind of like you went
through high school during the era that
was still on fire yeah where you in
college yes those into it and then I
think I got really depressed when like
grading suddenly if the court wasn't
graded it wasn't worth anything and then
I get some cards graded and they come
back like bad grades I'm like oh man
everything's over all these rookie cards
like I bought for like these coward
Kentucky's at bottom for like thirty
bucks
mint rookies which would if there was a
PSA nine or something would be worth yes
hundred thousand yeah and and they're
basically now they're coming back six
five like it was just so depressing I'm
like also this card is like still only
worth twenty bucks
it was just I was like you know I forget
this then I got like a resurgence you
know like in my mind I'm like okay I'm
gonna just like get back into it start
buying some tens I'm like really good
when you got older and all the have some
more money and stuff and and then and
then I just yeah yeah absent flows what
was it so what happened when did you
take your entrepreneurial game to the
next level college after college college
I did did a hedge fund in college learn
learned a ton there that was kind of a
cool thing but the next let's talk about
that that's a little that's a pretty
intense sleep yeah college you decide
you know what a hedge fund well I
started I was so into stocks as a kid I
started tracking stocks like ten years
old like a book like Kellogg here's the
place every Sunday and then I started
reading books on the McKean Edwards
technical analysis of stock trends and
derivative books where you will have
great were you a good student no yeah me
neither
so what I was reading they were reading
like you know history and reading
literature and I was reading you know
books on derivatives well this is what
I'm talking about I would sit in class
because
I knew I was gonna be in the wine
business at that point and would
memorize the Wine Spectator and would
like a look at my friends who were
making fun of me that I was bad soon I'm
like you're reading The Scarlet Letter
yeah like [ __ ] you [ __ ] Catcher in the
Rye yeah
I'm sure I'll figure out the theme of
that [ __ ] story in like cliffnotes
could tell you really quick I couldn't
even read that [ __ ] ya know I got yellow
thing but I got through this I could
read the summary the clip those take the
test in like drunk
Oh Bart Simpson like character and right
like it I used to write nice Eisley
literally they would give me a test
inning miss Horvath if you're listening
to this that anybody knows miss Horvath
from North hundred in high school 1992
1994 please send her this because she
might remember this she would give me a
literature test and I would do two
things
draw a character literally in the answer
number one draw this Bart Simpson
looking like character and number two
write her a charming sentence of like I
really like the way that you handled
Brian Bennington outburst last week and
you know I know that I might not be
achieving to the level that you want but
I really really like what you're doing
for Megan Murphy like here she's like
you know like and that that's so rarely
work but once in a blue moon I guess
before that I was I was a saving lady
true though there was one test I'll
never forget it was like I knew nothing
I didn't read the books I knew nothing
and I just sat down put my name on the
front and I asked I said you know when
you're done can you bring your paper up
and go to study halls you see yeah what
do you finish yeah I just go to study
hall so I got up gave it in she goes
mark you didn't answer anything like I
said well I don't know anything
she said you know this is gonna be a
zero I said I assumed it would be zero
yeah because I didn't do anything and
then she said you know this means you're
gonna get in out of this class I said
yeah I pretty much assumed yeah I assume
that walking in day one before I would
cover my book with a brown paper bag I
already knew an F was well on its way
all right so you saw a hedge fund did
you make money it actually did not it's
my recommend or not the brave it was
pretty much luck yeah and then it would
the stress of
because my I'm like yeah forget it was
money whose money where you tell it was
like so funny we had like this a couple
like wealthy kids on campus got the
money from their dad it's like I don't
even know who would give like a cup of
college so then what happened Lenny I
did this with a friend so let me just we
actually made some money but it was too
stressful and then we you know gave
money back shut it down
and then and then the next thing I did I
went to work in a bank because I knew
stocks and derivatives and anything as a
kid and so went to work at Bankers Trust
and and then got into financial risk
management which was kind of a hot thing
then we're like you're managing like
what's the risk the bank's taking on
their proprietary books and derivatives
and options and stocks and bonds and
stuff like that
our but hedge yeah so I got into risk
which was which is pretty cool right up
my alley I was always good at math and
stuff so I like that so this was early
mid 20s yeah early 20s and how did you
so you were having fun making some money
having fun
make some money yep okay saving some
money and and then you got this idea
with this guy love that you know there
was no there was no certification exam
for waitso lakhs love like you're in the
West
yeah so there's a loose sitting out
there right now they should reach out go
ahead yeah so so you know basically in
this field of financial management it's
pretty new there's a chartered financial
analyst there's a you know CPA there's
all these you know certification exams
nothing for financial risk managers so I
kind of just got the idea like why don't
why don't we create a certification exam
for risk managers everyone's like dude
you're like 24 years old like who's
gonna take your exam like how you can't
just you can't just certify people its
risin why everything works yeah I'm just
gonna certify people and so so when I
trade rocks and then we believe that
cash was right yeah and now people think
cryptocurrency I mean so what so it's
crazy so so people say all the time they
said well how do you do something like
that he gets started I said first of all
you don't overthink it basically put up
a website and we said here's everything
that's gonna be on the exam here's what
gonna test you for and
picked the date like a year out and we
said here's the date five hundred bucks
here's everything on the test how do you
mark how'd you how'd you market the
website you know keyword google keyword
search stuff what year was this
this is 96 mm-hmm so it's pre Google
maybe wasn't Google maybe it was a
search engine yes Jeeves I think I
remember the big moment was late to drop
the a store now it's just Jeeves I'm
like all right dog pile
yeah I don't know if you I'm going into
like hardcore old so do you member dogs
like Lykos yeah like yep okay so you did
that so and then we started getting
checks yeah like oh [ __ ] we got to write
this exam so me and love like sat down
and like yeah real quick cuz this is fun
for young entrepreneurs tell me the
moment when you came home and in your
mailbox you open it and there's an act
that first $500 check you were like holy
[ __ ] like holy [ __ ] that's really funny
some guy sent a check in like that's
really funny like this right no there's
like nothing yeah yeah and then another
check you know that we got 34 check to
made 17 grand in checks and like then we
looked each other love and I'm like I
guess we have to write this exam what
did what was love doing love level was
actually a risk manager also it credit
Swiss and you knew him from school or
you know we were you like them right
away yeah he's he's actually a rocket
scientist he's a nuclear like you know
guy from Russia a good friend and it was
just fun and and and so yeah so we set
like weekend after weekend writing this
exam I'm like you know he's older than
me but but I'm 24 you know like just
learning the field and we're like
writing this examination that we're
gonna give people and we wrote the exam
we went down and got lab was there the
guy yeah we administered the exam to
these 34 people and we got back and
we're like all right now how do we pass
and who we fail so we basically just
decided we were gonna like you know the
top of 50% we're gonna pass and the
bottom 50% we're gonna fail we just drew
a line we sent the certificates out said
hey you're past your you're an frm
and now by the way this exam is given
like 50 countries around the world to
like 10,000 people a year or something
something crazy like that today
right now right now is lab running it no
it's you guys shoulder we just gave it
away it's a long story
all right so you build this thing then
what happens
yeah then that was kind of that so yeah
we built it worked on it stuff we gave
it to the not-for-profit Association
called garb okay and and there's got the
bug for Entrepreneurship it's like
really fun to like basically just create
something from nothing so I'm about
seven years into my banking career chief
risk officer now at Sanwa Bank as a
youngster
yeah like 27 years old basically we seen
a ton of money okay making like a half a
million bucks a year 27 my top of the
world chief risk officer it couldn't
life couldn't be better for someone my
age that's great and then I just I just
had this thing like I didn't want to be
sitting here 10 20 year I didn't want it
like yeah being banking I wanted to
start a business to be an entrepreneur
so I just got the nerve up and decided
I'm gonna quit and be an entrepreneur
and I just went into my boss's office
and I just one day woke up I just said
I'm gonna do it I went in there and I
said hey I'm I'm gonna quit and be an
entrepreneur like the guy laughed at me
what year was that this was 99 yeah long
before it was cool to do what you did
yeah 99 okay and and he laughed at me
thought I was crazy
said hey didn't you just have a baby I
said yeah I said you know you may be
paying you a lot of money I said yeah I
know he said well we must have a great
idea so I don't have an idea yet but I
know I need to like focus it go all-in
on this thing and just basically cut the
line and just go all-in and he's like
man you're serious he's like well here
I'm gonna put 50 grand in I don't know
what it is but like if you're crazy
enough to do this I think you're gonna
make it work and you put 50 grand I
didn't know anybody with money at the
time like so he could put 50 grand in
and basically he introduced me to two
friends and they introduced me to two
friends and two friends I wind up
pitching like a hundred and twenty angel
investors right because this was the
last this was the first reason right
this was the first era of like this
silicon but like this was a hot time
yeah 99 was yeah
similar to now where like the nest that
you could crash like a year later I'm
aware yeah which is why I'm saying the
story because there's a bunch of dopes
right now about to quit think they're
gonna do something and lose and I want
to think sure they're very
good and they love with you know they
think this through cuz it's cool again
and this was the first time it was cool
to do that and so what was the business
it was a sports stock market it was
actually where you can buy instance
called the pit you can buy and sell
athletes like stocks we had a ticker
read market makers we had price charts
and things and you can basically go in
and buy like I remember I will tell you
my Pitt story oh you know the pit not
only do I know the pit Mart I decided
that Josh Beckett and the Marlins were
gonna beat the Yankees in the World
Series yeah so I went on the pit and
bought a ton of Beckett Josh Beckett
rookie and the night they beat the Yanks
and he like pitched the gem I sold them
all and made a nice little chunk oh that
is so you sold at the tops yeah some of
the tops and that was it was basically
inside of a year started it built it
sold it inside of a year and exit it was
a Marlin yeah yes we we actually gave
money a little bit money it was five
million we raised and we sold it for 5.7
so people made a little bit of money in
time of the market crash yeah and you
learned and learned and everyone was
like I can't look at my money back
like on this thing like I lost
everywhere else like the whole market
yeah it was a [ __ ] market that was just
a [ __ ] show and and so yeah so everyone
that's 60 angel investors they're all
like hey listen this is amazing like if
you do something again count me in right
because you won during a time that few
did yeah yes it was a great year for me
too with winelibrary.com like I was
really winning then because the jokes
were making about people spending money
on TV before we started this podcast I
was doing the the reason I knew the pit
was I'm like this is innovation yeah
like I don't want to hold my spleen
everybody right now in the sports card
world is like who's this guy I've been
doing this the whole time quietly in a
different way and like the pit was
probably one of the more it's funny you
bring that up so one of the times I
really really looked at the market for
the first time post being into it from
87 so funny coming back though it's so
easy to look back and say we just we
just could have been huge like you know
we just had to create a proxy for the
athletes that's right in the actual card
and if we would have done that and just
like but the concept of the card like I
look I think physical goods are a real
part of society
I think there's some startups right now
building that are gonna build a true
marketplace they're gonna hold the cards
yeah and it's gonna work yeah I think
that's gonna work
uh so the pit happens I understand you
put a W up a tiny W but a huge W in my
mind because I know how hard it was to
navigate during that time you found this
exit obviously I understand why the
Angels I would do the same
I'm an angel and do that at a time so
like okay this kid's got it yeah what
happens next
yeah and then inside of top so I was out
they sent me to see how to run this game
company called wits kids right
and that's like I've always been like
really about numbers and analytics and
spreadsheets and I was so mathematical
and that was the first real experience I
think everyone needs this to get that
the other side of the story you know the
sort of softer side and and the gamer is
it was all passion driven everything
everything that gamers thought about was
was like related to the quality of the
product and passion and numbers didn't
matter and so I remember I made a big
mistake actually there was a game board
and the game board was like you know
let's say it was 14 inches or something
you know the game board gamers played
and stuff and it was like way more
expensive than like a twelve inch I was
like two inches shorter
it was way cheaper we're gonna save a
ton of money like a million bucks a year
and I'm like guys did they really care
about these X 2 inches come on twelve
twelve inch looks just as good as a
fourteen an we're gonna save a million
bucks and some people in the gaming
industry said no you can't do that you
don't understand and I said it seems
make these squares a little bit short
you know whatever disaster they rebelled
then it was a the whole thing blew up
but I can it was like appreciated that
that it's not all math and numbers it
was that was that was that the first
time that really in your face you're
like [ __ ] the gray matters as much as
the black and white yes yeah yeah the
gray matter I really learned I came from
the you know it's funny we have so many
similarities and I came from the
opposite direction yeah I was so great
and intuitive yeah right
I sold my entire card collection and
went into comic books and toys for
months before the market collapsed Wow
cuz I could because I could I was I was
great yeah you're into I was great I
think you know and so and over the last
twenty years I've developed more
appreciation for the black and white and
but I still am a gray leader
with a respect for black and white and I
would argue that you probably based on
your natural talents a black and white
leader with a respectful yeah no I think
it's funny you say that I I think I've
actually gone to the other side Wow
I've done full-on so like I I am well
that's even more awesome and speaks to
why you you went on to have two monsters
after that because it it it speaks to
you have the natural talent to be such a
juggernaut in black and white and I can
only close the gap on black and white so
much yeah I can only get so interested
in numbers it's that if that's
interested I know what I don't know to
like the numbers it's great but I often
probably know 80 90 percent of the time
I'm looking to why the numbers aren't
telling the story well the numbers as
you know almost always are looking
backwards yeah yeah that's where people
get [ __ ] yeah
they're like Gary this is now like
that's nice that's last year yeah I
don't give a [ __ ] about that cuz we have
to sell this thing tomorrow yeah okay
so what happens next so then got this
idea for diapers.com
which was and literally people say how
do you get the idea I was just on google
searching keywords to see how many times
they were surged back then you can see
how many times the research I remember
and it was like diapers were searched
200,000 times in the month I'm like
that's so interesting you can't buy
diapers online not even Amazon you
couldn't really buy him it could pricey
they were like inflated prices I'm like
wow diapers everyone needs diapers like
and it's a pain in the butt if I can
deliver them overnight great service at
good prices isn't every mom in America
gonna like want to do that and that was
the like original thesis going in and
people said that's great but you can't
ship diapers overnight because you're
gonna lose a ton of money and there are
lost leader for brick and mortar for a
reason I said well yeah but that that's
right they're a loss leader for a reason
because they drive people into the store
so I'm not gonna make money on diapers
on my I'm gonna make money on everything
else and so so I just had to go and this
is pretty much self-funded I did this
with with another friend Vinnie and I
need a [ __ ] like I need like a
reservoir dogs like poster with you Lev
black slacks at Vinnie I mean I'm not
sure if you've actually been a good
entrepreneur or your undercover
mob life and you just like force people
into like you're gonna make this you're
gonna buy these diapers or you're gonna
hear from [ __ ] live you know people
so so literally started this business
and and we're selling a box of diapers
literally for ninety cents so we're
gonna buy them for down home for 90
cents P&G wouldn't sell his Huggies
wouldn't sell us kimberly-clark we had
to go to Costco and BJ's buy them buy
them and then sell them and make I knew
that every Bob I knew that yes we ran in
every box lot of leaders are smart and
people like but because we have much
funding do you guys put in like how much
did you guys give yourself a runway I
mean our celsa started we was it was
just me and him did everything we put it
like up on your grand each or something
it was like super small honey yeah and
how much did you pay for diapers calm or
did it start as diapers calm it started
what as 1-800 things because we couldn't
afford that figured that's why there was
that comment 600 grand the domain at the
time when you bought it yeah yeah big
number that we had but we had raised
like four million bucks series a so what
happened was you and Vinny got enough
action going and then you went raised
capital yeah mm-hmm 11 million run rate
and we showed mr. on cohorts and things
were yeah we kind of boot adapted we
were to almost a million a month in
revenue driving to BJ's buy the diapers
- [ __ ] you
sell them out seriously yeah 11 million
run rate on I mean at that point you had
somebody with a van going to BJ's right
yeah yeah no no that first it was you in
the car with us in the car here's the
funny the funny thing was here I like
kids the most important part of this
whole [ __ ] story is this when you're
the kind of kid that grabs weeds for
four hours a day or shovel snow for
seven hours or make sets all summer long
while everybody else is playing you
build a gear inside of you that leads to
the humility to actually go and pick up
the diapers
yeah at BJ's even after you've had some
levels of success even after you made
five hundred thousand dollars a year
when you were twenty seven even like my
mom and I always make jokes to each
other I was when she does something I'm
almost like you can take a girl from
Russia
but you can't take Russia from the girl
and that's how I think about it like so
many my friends are like why don't you
hire people to like bid for you on eBay
and like like what are you doing sports
car yeah ha time right now I'm like I'm
gonna do the work yeah you do work do
the work that's how you learn you do
[ __ ] learn the D - intimate details of
everything but anyway a thousand cases
pologize one more time mark because I
want value for the audience this is why
I don't begrudge students I don't
begrudge smart people or people that
like to learn i begrudge just staying
only in classrooms and books because you
never do which means you actually don't
know yeah yeah I agree
we got 2000 cases a day now it was
untenable like you just like PJs and
Costco were pumped yeah well we would
have to clear up multiple BJ's we could
oh are you making like backroom do you
go to the integers and be like hey let's
see yeah oh they're a bunch of time why
don't you just keep the [ __ ] things
on the pallets we're coming back it up
that's exactly strike force yeah so but
here's the here's that here's the great
thing we had this deal where they would
do that if we left them diapers for
their customers we'd always leave them
survivors like then we couldn't do more
than a thousand cases a day it was just
impossible
what if we're - Procter & Gamble again
it where was your warehouse like garage
yard like Johnny's yeah I love it so so
then we had to buy direct from Procter &
Gamble still doin house in case today
like we're not selling you think it's
not gonna it's not gonna work we're not
selling you like dude we can't we can't
buy all the diapers so then we said
alright you know what we know we're
gonna do we're gonna go to BJ's we're
gonna go we're taking all their diapers
I don't care if they don't stack this
the [ __ ] like we're taking all the
diapers you know why because when they
screamed at us and they said like you
can't take all the diapers like yeah we
can and we did and they're like I'm like
listen you could fix this problem you
can fix this and they did they called
proctoring Kimmel and pocketing Emma
called us and said hey listen we still
don't believe in you BJ's is a real
important customer they told us to sell
you so we will but we don't think it's
gonna work and we still think it's you
know and and that's how we got Procter
and Gamble and then was once you got
Proctor you got everybody else yeah and
what's ironic is like just I don't know
a year ago I'm walking around the office
and Procter and Gamble is in there and I
see the presentation and I pop in
okay what do you guys doing it's like oh
we're just talking about market share
diapers how you know how it's like you
know X percent online and it's going to
70 percent online and how people and
then we're gonna come to the store to
buy diapers anymore I'm like oh
interesting okay great great how much
actually it's a fun question because
this how much do you play for that
moment honestly on some real [ __ ] like
yeah me too like I I would argue with
you that I believe that's the only
reason I do what I do for a living yeah
it's is that that feeling is so fun
that's like like the feeling of all my
team who was making fun of me behind my
back for buying sports cards a year and
a half ago and I know them I'm watching
them and they're giggling behind my back
silly he liked it when he was a kid like
it's not gonna work
- then like watch them all scramble now
and like I feel like all borrowing money
from their parents they put all into
sports cards it's like I do it for that
not for me
it's the game but you for that I told
you so moment I do fun things like that
all the time even like go to the horse
track figure out a way to like beat the
system and it could be like turn like
you can't bet too much because you'll
move to odds but you know bed 100 bucks
and be guaranteed to win like 120 is
really fun like it's 20 bucks I don't
need 20 bucks it's just that you figured
it out figured it out did you love the
mom it's different word count in
Atlantic City how fun that was going
down there and like as a kid as a
teenager so glad I didn't have this math
skill level I would have been completely
obnoxious like you know I was more on
like I think like you know it's funny I
really have the grey version of this I'm
like like all the things literally
everything that I thought America was
gonna do happened like for example right
now i 100% know that straight young men
are gonna wear makeup in 12 years that
male makeup is a real category money in
the bank can't wait to show this clip in
12 years on whatever the tick-tock and
instagram is it's locked it's already
happened I know the dollar 20 now as you
can imagine I'm in the process of
building what machine I'm building for
infrastructure long term we played it a
little bit different like but very
similar but
at some point I'm gonna be ready in my
career to say okay that's what's gonna
happen and I'm gonna start the Olay or
the glossier or the whatever and it's
I'm gonna sell for four billion dollars
and I'm gonna call you and be like
already by the Jets and let's go yeah
well let me invest first we gotta talk
sports cards off like it's about to get
so uncomfortably hot the next 24 months
okay well I'm ready to come in now I
mean you know what you know you know
what you know what this money you
appreciate this like here you're sitting
by the way because we're wrapping up
diapers.com goes and crushes crushes he
then goes up he sells that to Amazon he
then goes and starts jet comm at that
point because it was a great Jersey yeah
I always was like at that point in my
career I was getting so much credit for
this little wine business ecommerce
thing I was like why aren't they looking
at the diapers.com guy he's thought it
way bigger than me
then you start jet and I see that I'm
like [ __ ] that's gonna and I knew you
know it's funny to hear to Costco BJ's
story because I remember how you
position that and I'm like that's good
and then the Walmart acquisition which
is a huge one and congratulations on
that and you're still there three and
half years later which is an impressive
part of the conversation that was
obvious to me and now you're doing now
you're becoming almost like you know now
with the way entrepreneurship is I mean
you literally raced Jerry Rice in the
forty at the NFL Combine this lacks we
I'm excited that you're starting to get
some I've always thought you were wildly
underrate there's very few people in
last decade that I've watched operate
and now that I'm getting to know you a
little better we had a meeting not too
long ago and now we're doing this I'm
like oh this makes sense like your
PlayBook is something I deeply respect
and i I've always felt that out of all
the entrepreneurs in this last decade
that you were quite under the radar and
you know I don't know your personality
traits and there's you know there's
plenty people building trillion-dollar
companies that nobody's ever heard of
and there's plenty people have a million
followers on Instagram that are gonna
flop in four minutes that people think
are good at entrepreneurship but I've
always really respected you from afar
and I really like that you like sports
cars oh thanks
we're where I'm going with that though
is like I think the reality is is that
it's a skill that never I almost feel
like it's a skill that never gets out of
your body yeah you know like I'm sitting
here with you right now your 48 I'm 44
and when I tell you I'm like my god like
we're gonna be having this conversation
in 40 years yeah like we're gonna be
sitting somewhere Mars the track at a
flea market
you know the boardroom and we're
literally gonna be like oh we've known
each other for 40 years and we said 40
years ago that we would be sitting here
doing this [ __ ] and that's just the
nature of the game I don't know what it
is I have more Drive now than I did
before it's not even think it's momentum
of being in your spot it's not even
close I would take a [ __ ] on 28-year old
me yeah that kid could even compete I
couldn't he's not even in my world I
feel this thing that that dude sucks I
would beat the [ __ ] out of him
I could work harder now that I did yeah
100% yeah I agree
anyway what any anything that we didn't
touch on as we wrap up here or any
parting wisdom for the kids and then not
kids that are listening know anybody
who's thinking about starting a business
though I'd say go for it
right cuz the loss is worth it right
yeah do you say go for it that blazin
because you also realize that regret is
scarier than everything and if it's
really in you whether you completely
like I keep telling people I thought
yours withdraws you too I also think
like if if you're scared to do it and
you do it you're gonna put in the best
you've got and that's what it's gonna
take but if you but if you're putting
the best you've got you're gonna make
things happen I don't know where it's
gonna lead you're gonna go through
failures you might some ups and downs
but if you just stay at it and just go
after it and market real and I think
once people start making the world about
happiness not money then this is gonna
make a lot more logic yes because a lot
of people go for it have a nice home in
Summit New Jersey right now make for 12
a year
life is good kids in private school good
[ __ ] even Jersey Shore house like good
[ __ ] good [ __ ] and they're gonna listen
to us to Jersey bozos and I'm like [ __ ]
it I'm unhappy I'm going for it yeah and
the story for Hank is it's actually
gonna fail because what Hank was a
number six you know the number six
yeah great number six yeah you know it's
the Scottie Pippen thing Scottie Pippen
is all-time overrated in my opinion
because he had a great all-time number
one hiding it and when he went to
Portland and he went to Houston no and
and by the way
Hank right now at for 12 years listening
to us and go for it let me just finish
this thought and I could see you want to
jump in going up no I have to go okay go
bathroom so go I'll finish this go yeah
go take a peek so let me finish my
thought one I find it fascinating that
mark couldn't hold it like I just think
that's all-time interesting out of all
the things number two on the scottie
pippen thing it's not to razz scotty and
of course it's coming from a Knicks fan
who's bitter but Hank if you're
listening marks right not because of the
money but because of the happiness
because you're 44 and your life is good
but you hate your [ __ ] job you hate
it you you really know you actually hate
it but you like your life at what you
need to ask yourself is do you like your
life because of the financial things
that are happening and that you look
happy versus actually being happy
because I can tell you when you make
that jump and you fail and you have to
have the shame and that's the word I'm
going to use the shame to move your
family out of summit and move into
another town and you got a 12 and a 9
year old who are now scrying cuz they're
going to a different school and they
went from being fancy to maybe less
fancy like that is a lot of carnage that
most people don't have the stomach for
the problem is that nobody tells you is
that at 72 years old you spend the next
20 years of your life in regret cuz you
weren't happy and that is not [ __ ]
easy and I don't say this lightly but
when I hear mark say go for it I
actually understand it because I spend a
lot more time analyzing what 70 and 80
and 90 year old say and I understand why
a 44 year old doesn't have the strength
to disappoint their kids or to look
stupid in front of their friends or to
like confuse the world and it's easier
at 27 even with a new kid than it is at
44 which is why I love the Internet
mark and I are by probably we would be
totally different men in our careers if
the internet didn't come along if you
listen to his stories Google and diapers
and and landing page and $500 check and
the pit we are the byproducts of our age
of the entrepreneurs that had practical
opportunity on the internet that would
have never existed if we were 40 years
earlier that's what I want for everybody
to realize we understood that and that's
what we navigated on you can have a side
hustle - so we talked about Hank quit
let's talk about Hank instead of golfing
for four hours on Saturday let's talk
about Hank instead of coming home and
having a glass of wine and watching the
news The Daily Show or sports if you're
really unhappy with what you do for a
living
give me back those 14 hours that you
waste each week and set up a landing
page set up an Instagram account around
Star Trek or soccer or sports cards side
hustle practicality with patience where
you build it where where Mark and Lev
had a look at each other and say [ __ ]
maybe there's something here now notice
what he did he did what I do do [ __ ]
that's and then let the market show you
there's something there and then grow
right he's like I just gotta put the
time in write the time this goes brother
it's the weeds it's pulling the weeds
too many people are entitled and don't
want to waste their time when their time
ain't worth [ __ ]
it's gonna be an ending Thank You Pat
thank you
you